hello I'm Joe at you very on the CEO of
Deloitte in the session that I wanted to
spend a few minutes talking about was
the mic reporter session on moving from
a world where we have CSR corporate
social responsibility moving into some
sort of a business model where we have
corporate social values the difference
being that one of them is sort of a
philanthropic bucket that has a finite
amount of dollars associated with it the
other is really trying to come up with a
business model it creates a compelling
case for for-profit entities like
ourselves to invest in some of those
social values and then by creating a
win-win both in terms of a proper
orientation more importantly solving
some societal value that we see as a
whole so for me that was one of my
favorite moments and no certainly one of
those telling moments and someday we're
going to take back to our US firm back
in the States so I hope you enjoy this
little clip and talk with all you soon